this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
so that breaking news right now mass are
back for
clark county commissioners voting in on
people working indoors
in public spaces to wear a mask for
employees
yeah so clark county commissioner is
just passing this mandate now in an
emergency meeting joe mohler was there
he's live with the changes and when they
go into effect
joe good evening you two this is a very
lengthy heated meeting happening here at
the government center for the past
several
hours first it was the health district
who recommended people wear masks
indoors and public settings but
the county did decide that it would be
employees who have to wear masks
indoors in public settings this all goes
into effect thursday at midnight and
will go
through august 17th this means employees
who are in a public space indoors need
to wear that mask
but can take them off in an office or
cubicle now the county also wants
mitigation plans for major companies
like casinos stores
and businesses with venues that host
more than 250 people
some think more needs to be done people
worried about masks and shutdowns share
their thoughts during public comment
shane you guys come on i'm asking you
please
let us live make it a choice please
why are we masking people up when masks
have been proven to not stop a virus
businesses are also supposed to be
posting signage that recommends people
wear masks indoors
there is also a push to increase the
amount of people being vaccinated
every day many commissioners say this is
this crisis is just getting worse
because so many people are still
not vaccinated again this goes into
effect tomorrow at midnight so on
thursday people
employees working in public settings and
doors will have to wear those masks and
county commissioners say this is
an ongoing conversation and if changes
need to happen in the future
they'll do so reporting live in downtown
las vegas joe muller 8 news now